we are all looking for a reason to feel
good something so simple yet somehow
made into something so complicated we
often have this tendency to think that
we need a reason to feel good about
being alive that we need to do things
own things and achieve things and
perhaps that is the problem of course it
is important that we participate in
external activities because it
stimulates our experience of life in
gages us in the give-and-take and
pragmatically speaking it is required to
establish financial stability and
general safety but the things that we do
and acquire should not be the sole
factors by which we derive feeling good
about life the material world is in flux
cycles rotate in ways that are often
arbitrary and out of anyone's control
what was new and cool last year is
likely not this year and things that we
once thought would make us feel good
forever like a nice house a cool car a
career promotion etc ultimately at some
point fade into the background of our
lives and no longer make us feel the
same level of joy and appreciation
compared to when we first acquired them
and so these kinds of reasons to feel
good just become reasons to look for
more reasons to feel good pushing us
further and
they're away from ever being able to
just simply feel good when we depend our
ability to feel good on things outside
of ourself we over complicate something
that is inherently simple the reason to
feel good needs no reason beyond itself
if your goal is to feel good then you
already have the only reason you need
you have the spirit of life and
positivity you believe that life is so
incredible that there should be no
moment where you do not feel intoxicated
by its bliss so if you are not already
feel good right now
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder